all right let's talk about iran
we always talked about going there
together remember we will still go there
i think we are we will still go there
and really adam's going to go with us
what what's the over under on when you
would actually go to iran
what's the overall over under you need
an administration
like trump for at least eight years for
me to be able to go to iran
you know why you want to really talk
about it from that end of course
okay let's talk about it before we get
into the topic in order for
me to be able to go back to iran there
needs to be a revolution in iran
okay so in order for there to be a right
we're not going unless there's a
revolution there has to be republicans
because there has to be a different
way of living democracy uh women have to
have the freedom that they once had and
tourism needs to be at where it needs to
be and today with the sanctions
financial it's not a good situation
right now to go to iran okay
so until by the way we're very close to
get to that point
of a revolution but it's not going to
happen because biden got elected and
i'll explain to you why so
iran's top nuclear scientist was
assassinated by remote control machine
gun place in the back of another card
the country's media says
the iranian defense ministry has given
few details of the killing but has
pointed the fingers at israel
new information about the attack was
reported sunday however the farce
saying factory zodia stopped and left
his car
after mistaking several bullets that had
just hit his vehicle for engine trouble
at this point far said nissan pickup
truck stopped 150 meters or about 492
feet
from factorizate and a gun mounted on
the back of the truck
opened fire hitting him twice in the
back and once in the spine three
security cars had been traveling with
factory zelda and a bodyguard who
launched himself over the scientist's
body
who uh was also shot first reported
according to fars after the hit on
faculty saturday was complete the nissan
truck exploded
the entire attack lasted three minutes
the news agency reported so what's
really going on over here
what's really going on here i'll tell
you one thing here's here's what you
have to here's here's what you have to
realize i kind of give you a little bit
of it and then i'll go into which with
some of the thoughts you guys may have
number one what what has happened the
last 12 months to iran what's happened
last 12 months to iran
a lot has happened over the last 12
months to iran in the last 12 months
iran lost their number two in power
qasem
which by the way he was a potential
candidate to be the leader of iran
he died okay it's about a year ago and
we remember how that happened and when
it happened drone strikes and you
remember
how iran retaliated they hit a military
base with nobody being at the base just
to show that their people
that we retaliated but nothing took
place
then you have fast forward quietly on
august
7th of this year i believe august 7th
of this year they went and and took out
the number two guy
of al qaeda is what they did this year
all if you want to pull up the pictures
everybody knows who they took out this
year
uh august 7th of this year they took out
uh uh abu mohammed al masri
uh abu mohammed al-masri now some of you
who don't know who he is let me kind of
give you the background of how powerful
of a guy he's he's a number two guy in
al-qaeda
he was walking in the streets of iran
with his daughter who's married to osama
bin laden's
son they killed both of them they killed
him
and his daughter well i'm going to get
to who killed that who okay because
you're connected to them
who killed them right so he ends up
getting killed
august 7 1998. now what is special
august 7 2020
we're talking four months ago what is so
special about august 7 2020
exactly 22 years ago august 7th
1998 what happened in africa embassy
there was a bombing at africa embassy
and 220 people
were killed at the u.s embassy two u.s
embassies
do you know who led that project this
man right here
on the same exact day 22 years ago
that he did not a coincidence 22 years
later
they kill him and his daughter in the
streets of iran and guess what iran says
when they kill him
nothing you know why they said nothing
you didn't hear about it they didn't
talk about it in the news they didn't
advertise it
they were embarrassed and they didn't
want to even report that we're going to
retaliate because he's part of what
al qaeda they can't come out there and
say hey we cannot believe you took out
the number two guy
in al qaeda his daughter's married to
who osama bin laden's
son okay so you got some soleimani
then you have abu mohammed over here
that gets killed and then comes who
and then comes fakley zade yeah who is
the number one scientist in iran now who
is factory
nuclear scientist in iran who is he okay
you have to go back years ago there was
a project called kai if you want to put
a
pull up project uh ahmad project ahmad
uh ahmad project was one of the first
projects they came out with reverse iran
scientific
scientific project started in 18 1989
stopped in 03 by the iaea
that is suspected by israel to have
nonetheless and continued with the aim
of developing nuclear weapons who led
this
who was the leader of this project
factories are there okay
then there's the project go to the next
one then go to the next one
the next project was called spnd the
iranian defense ministry known as spmd
which was also an
organization to go out and build a
nuclear plant in iran by the same
scientist
led by who fakhri zadeh okay so now go
to a talk
that uh benjamin netanyahu gave in 2018
i want to say in april
you have that video i send it to you kai
if you can prepare that video right
there
this is a talk he gave april of 2018
okay
and he's given the message about what's
going on with iran now watch what he
says
about faculty's other just press play
turn on the audio yeah
you'll see what he says here when he
says remember the name key word
two and a half years ago netanyahu says
remember the name go ahead and press
the new directive of iran's minister of
defense the work would be split
watch this into two parts covert and
overt
a key part of the plan was to form new
organizations to continue the work
this is how dr museum head of project
about put it remember that name
remember that name so here's his
directive it's right here
and he says the general aim is to
announce the closure of project ahmad
but then he adds special activities you
know what that is
special activities will be carried out
under the title of scientific know-how
developments
and in fact this is exactly what iran
proceeded to do
it continued this work in a series of
organizations over the years
and today in 2010 the 2018 this work is
carried out by sapond that's an
organization
inside iran's defense ministry and you
will not be surprised
to hear that sapond is led by the same
person who led project ahmad
dr zadeh and also not coincidentally
many of sapon's key personnel worked
under farisa on project ahmad
pause it so this atomic positive right
there okay so watch this here
so you got kasem soleimani you got abu
mohammed who was the number two god
al-qaeda
you got some solemn who was a number two
guy in iran
and you got fake lizard who was the
number one nuclear scientist in iran
okay who was leading america during that
time who was a president
trump who is the prime minister of
israel
netanyahu benjamin netanyahu okay so
where does this go to next where does it
go to next
well if you watch this go to the tweet
of john brennan go to the tweet of john
brennan look what he says here's what
brennan says and
for for folks who don't know who john
brennan is john brennan is not a trump
guy
john brennan is a obama and a biden guy
he said on november
national security and for obama yeah
yeah no just saying like he's
but he's also on he's not a trump camp
he's clearly not a trump nominee
he's actually a trump hater but he's a
high up in the uh he is on the bifi
and biden and obama's side november 27
he tweets
a associate press comes out saying iran
is scientist that israel alleged that
the islamic republic military nuclear
program before it was spanning has been
killed in a shootout iran
state television said he says this was a
criminal act
and highly reckless it risks lethal
retaliation and a new round of regional
conflict iranian leaders would be wise
to wait for the return of responsible
american leadership was he talking about
on the global stage and to resist the
urge to respond
against perceived culprits let me read
that one more time this is what you call
sign language okay
this is a message saying khamenei we
understand you're upset right now
please read my tweet i can't contact you
right now because it's going to come out
i'm telling you read my tweet
iranian leaders would be wise to wait
for the return of responsible american
leadership on the global stage hence
biden to replace trump
and to resist the urge to respond
against perceived culprits so wait for
what
does this mean biden's going to give him
that 150 billion dollar
deal that they had before does this mean
biden's going to give you that money
that you had is going to remove the
sanctions just be patient we know you
lost your number one nuclear scientist
we're sorry be patient and does this
mean
that john brennan is not supportive of
benjamin netanyahu that this is a
criminal act and highly reckless because
in the streets
of politics between iran israel people
knew
who was behind this and they're
comfortable saying it
that who was behind this and that is
netanyahu that is an open conversation
that people are having
no one's surprised by this so what does
this mean what does this mean
here's here's how i process this i
foresee
i foresee nothing taking place
over the next few weeks i foresee
iran getting the money that they want
when mine comes in
i foresee sanctions getting lower and
maybe even going away
when biden takes office i foresee
a massive attack from iran
to someone in the middle east they may
go straight at israel
but they're going to go to any of the
allies that's linked to
netanyahu any of the allies that was
towards trump's camp
when trump was here they're not going to
slow down
they are going to retaliate and it's not
going to be during
this term the next month or so but it is
going to happen
in the next four years and it will not
happen at a time when we're expecting it
so
i'm very surprised by john brennan's
tweet
whether you're right or not or whether
you're correct or not
whether you're anything you're saying or
not you officially didn't defend
netanyahu and netanyahu is one of the
most important allies us has had for a
long time
and things are about to get very
interesting in the middle east so
having said that i'm gonna turn it over
to you what are your thoughts there's a
couple questions
yeah clearly understand that john but
john brennan
is not active in government right now
he's sort of just a talking head whether
he's
anti-trump or pro-obama or pro-biden
unless he has a position he's a has-been
as trump likes to say right so he's not
this is his opinion i don't think
there's no policy
there's nothing that he's implementing
this is just an old guy's opinion
so i don't think there's any question
and i'm not sure if it was
uh israel that attacked uh how do you
say his name far
far far i'm not sure if that was them
that did it but i know for a fact it was
israeli technology
without i mean there was a was it a um
remote controlled machine gun that shot
up the car then the guy got out he
thought it was a
they hit a bump or something they got
out sprayed them down the bodyguard
tried to jump he got shot
that car blew up two minutes later boom
like that's israeli technology
for sure now i'm not sure who got into
iran and if it was mossad the israeli
like
cia who did it but this is clearly an
israeli technology type of move
why do you say that it to me it sounds
like the
last episode of breaking bad
there you go you remember that you kind
of look like a little walter
remote control machine gun walter white
yeah you don't remember that looking at
them right now
i'm wondering that yeah but so what do
you what are you wondering though
you're wondering is what you're
wondering was it led
by israel to do something like that or
you're saying
it was done by well somebody in israel
has got netflix
and so they're watching this and they
come to the end and they go hey guys
and that's a brilliant processing there
tom i'm not sure if it's art imitating
uh
life or life imitating art or whatever
it is but
i think we can all agree that israeli
technology is ridiculous when it comes
to this kind of stuff
um you have a good point i think the
biggest point here is what's gonna
happen with that 150 billion dollars the
you know entering the um the iran
nuclear deal trump got out of that as
soon as he came into office you know how
big it is to take out
a country's number two guy you know how
big it is to take out the number two to
al-qaeda
and do you know how big it is to take
out the number one nuclear scientist i
don't think you realize
like go to a sports team and take out
the number one guy
what happens take out go to a sports
team and take out the number two guy
what happens go to a company and take
out and see what happens
go to go to the denver broncos and take
out their top three quarterbacks and see
what happens
it's not like every single situation
it's not like every single day you can
find a
let me go put a job posting on monster
you're looking for a top nuclear
scientist
you know what i mean although i'm just
hiring for nuclear scientists anybody
got to experience it
being a nuclear scientist that doesn't
happen every day they lost someone legit
that they needed
to do what they wanted this is what i
mean
it's no secret why they blamed israel
this is what israel does they say
look we're not gonna fight a real war
we're gonna be very tactful
and tactical and we're gonna take out
your top people
and this is why the u.s and israel are
so tight this is what
they're doing you know all day every day
um
planning these types of attacks why go
to war when you could just take out
one guy take out the leader take out the
general
take out the top nuclear scientists um
but they're
although if if you're watching this if
you're watching this if you're saying
pat uh there's no way in the world
iran's gonna retaliate
in the next you know 12 months
24 months there's no way they're going
to retaliate
put thumbs down they're not going to
retaliate if you think
they're going to retaliate push thumbs
up if you think they are going to
retaliate
push thumbs up in the next 12 24 months
under by the administration
i'm actually really curious what you
think is going to be taking place tom do
you have any other strong opinions on
this
yeah i think so if i was running
an arm of the cia what i'd be doing
right now honestly
is i'd be modeling the response and how
i'd model response i'd look at all these
um
important dates anniversary dates
because in the middle east when you have
these hits and things and retaliations
are usually done very symbolically
and they pick a symbolic date or a
symbolic location and i'd be trying to
kind of model this because
iran is going to respond they are going
to respond in some way
somehow um and over there
you know i don't know if i was like the
number five nuclear scientist they say
hey now you're the number two and i said
yeah but don't put that in the paper
please
as soon as i get a loan number bad
things happen i don't want a loan number
no no i'm number 16. i'm an idiot man
you know i'm the number 16 nuclear
scientist here please get that straight
i was
you know no no you went like to you know
you were educated in the united states
makes sense tom was the number six guy
he jammed that when they sold it for 680
million dollars he got the check but he
was number six but the point i'm getting
to is i'm being serious
iran is going to respond and they're
gonna they're gonna
get together it's going to be very
symbolic and
it's going to be very you know forceful
and
you know unfortunately you know you get
a lot of civilians and people are
probably going to get hurt
and that's it's a world in which we live
the middle east
is a tough place it's got a lot of fuses
over there
and a lot of people that get easily
triggered for hundreds of years it's
been this way
and so one thing we have to respect the
united states is how much we don't
understand
and how much i appreciate your analysis
you just took us through pat
you walked through all the steps i think
americans need to do that and kind of
understand
and you know we can loop all this back
to the virginity test in london
where there's a culture over there that
has a certain set of beliefs but they're
also living with another culture
and that's what leads to this and so um
you know one man's misunderstanding is
another man's culture
iran iran is not you don't publicly
humiliate a community like iran
you you know how there's a friend uh you
know you know there's like if i if i
tell a joke at you
how do you take it like let's just if we
say stuff stuff about soyboy what does
it do to you
nothing yeah people don't realize it
doesn't bother you
like it doesn't bother you saying sober
mafia you even have fun with it yeah
to the point where we called a bunch of
people the other day every time i said
adam what did everybody say about adam
they love the guy right they love adam
it wasn't like it was five guys
or ten guys it was every phone call
loved at them
soybean mafia shout out right we're out
there you ever met anybody that if you
say
one thing to them they're so sensitive
that will that they will keep it forever
yeah and then they will retell you know
who i'm talking about just go too
personal like that in your life
that you publicly humiliated them
they're not going to let go of it
they're extremely wired in a different
way
they have ego at the highest level
they're very they're not as strong as
they act out to be they're actually not
strong they're weak they're not that
strong
but they will retaliate this is that
kind of a regime that they will
retaliate it's not going away they're
not going to machine specifically
the what the regime the regime's not the
culture not the people but there's no no
the people are dude are you kidding me
like i'd love to take you to tehran iran
and we go have a blast together i'd love
to go out there and
show you the the culture the history
rich history oh that
it's never about the people it's about
the regime it's about the philosophies
that the regime's running so it's going
to be interesting to see what happens in
iran so the
the bottom line is the regime is not
going to sit there and take this they
are not going to do it and
and they're going to do it during the
time where the opposing
leader of u.s is not going to retaliate
someone like joe biden a person like joe
biden is not going to say we're going to
if you don't do this
we're coming after you no person like
joe biden is going to say the following
speech
well i just want you to know under the
trump administration
if you allow the number two leader to
get killed rasam soleimani you think you
were doing the right thing
if you allow abu you know muhammad
get killed and then if you allow the
number one nuclear scientist that
scientist to get
if you do that you are this is not an
iran attacks
guess who biden's gonna blame iran
biden's gonna say
the attacks that iran just imposed on
two dot dot
dot dot is a byproduct of the
policies brought down by donald trump
remember when i said this just
remember when i said this kai make a
note on this in your notes
because you're going to make a note in
your phone notes say
podcast 29 iran nuclear
and put the time right now it's right
about one hour when i said this
right about one hour when i said this
that you're gonna have to come back and
reshoot it and
not re-shoot it cut it and it happened
next two to three years
that this is what's gonna be said you
will hear them say it and i'm gonna show
you that i said this that's what's gonna
be said
because they're not going to they're not
going to sit around they're going to
retaliate and biden's out's going to be
what it's not my fault surprise
administration that really pissed them
off
so what's going to happen next two three
four years and bottom line you think i
hope i'm wrong i hope i am
absolutely wrong is part of this going
to be the 150 billion that iran will
potentially receive like do you think
that's like
prediction time they need money you
think that they're gonna oh they're
gonna do it they're gonna get the money
back they're gonna get the sanctions cut
iran's gonna go become
powerful again in the middle east
they're not going away
because you think they're going to get
the money they're going to get the money
very quickly and you know what they're
going to say they're going to use a word
a very magical word they're going to say
peace
truths you know something like that
where it's a powerful word
and we're going to say oh wow there's
peace in iran you know that's what
they're going to use
who's biased and we're going to well 80
million people
are going to buy it 80 million people
are going to buy that 80 million people
going to say what a peaceful
noble thing to do about 80 million
people are buying it so if you're asking
the question i'll give you specific data
online it's about 80 million people and
one sitting at this table here well
you're saying
money or not iran is not looking for
peace no
way no looking for retaliation iran they
don't just dislike israel
they hate well we know that israel
that's not
and the difference between netanyahu
here's the other thing with netanyahu
also let me give you netanyahu's uh
site as well he's not a guy that's
sitting around not
ruffling feathers and not talking
publicly that presentation if you've
never seen this you've got to sit there
and watch that
it's the most eloquent presentation
powerpoint like you look at that and you
say this guy's probably prepared
to give this powerpoint at least 20
times before he gave it
netanyahu is also now one that's sitting
around afraid of iran
and again israel historically has been
known for having what the strongest air
force
historically they've always been known
israel has the best air force israel has
the best heirs for
air force now you're seeing these kinds
of creative attacks
technology technology is at a different
level right now when you have the u.s
you know if u.s has your back you can be
project toughness like we talked about
this with armenia
and the question is going to be if
they're going to have their back this
next time around
u.s is going to have israel's back of
course when do they not
the u.s is going to have israel's back
the way they're going to have it like
prior four years
i don't know about what do you mean four
years i passed 50 years i don't know
about that
has it been any different are you
kidding me you're saying under obama
israel was as tough as they were the
last four years no way saying that the
the israel and us relationships give me
two days to go show you exactly words
that was set under obama administration
towards israel to not
really protect them as much as it was
before all you need to do is go spend an
hour on land you'll realize how
iran israel was during obama's
administration right
let me get this straight you're saying
u.s had israel's back and u.s agreed to
give 150 billion dollars to iran but
that was part of the nuclear deal
nuclear testing right so you're giving
me money to stop doing nuclear testing
and first of all how you hold me
accountable to that
how do you even know if i'm not doing
rabbit hole conversation but how do you
actually do it honestly how do you
actually do it i assume that's what some
of the stuff they put in the deal
i'm gonna give you money to tell you
don't create nuclear war that's
brilliant that's a brilliant i've never
heard of that brilliant strategy before
you don't do it that way you do it with
measures to say if you do xyz
here's the price there is no price you
don't tell your kids
son please here's some money just
please stop saying bad words to your
mommy you don't you don't do that well
you say i'm sorry what did you say
no problem that xbox i'm taking it
straight to my office no xbox for three
weeks
that's how you do it and then they
realize okay that is serious you don't
do it and say
oh here's a hundred dollars guys please
when you play xbox don't raise your
voice what the hell
what what the hell kind of a negotiation
is that oh
here's some money please don't create a
nuclear bomb i don't think they should
have ever given iran are you any money
here's a country that goes around saying
medic bad on recount death upon america
you want to give them money let me get
this straight i sit here and i curse
your mother out
and you end up giving me 10 grand how
the hell does that make any sense well i
mean obviously the the point was to stop
their entire nuclear uh
so i give you 10 grand you give me 10
grand to say pat stop calling my mom out
would you would you give me if i kept
saying jokes about your
mom are you going to say yours 10 000
please stop
look i guess that's what u.s did i'm not
saying that the iran nuclear deal
i'm saying they had a deal in place you
bought niceness
what the hell do you mean you're buying
basically you're saying no matter what
amount of money that you gave i ran
they were not going to honor it that's
what you're saying no so trump's move to
pull out of the iranians
they're fabric the iranian fabric okay
i'm gonna go out there and i'm gonna say
okay you want me to give you money yes
perfect
uh allow every single social media in
your country all of it okay
allow every single one of our media in
your country if you'd kill
one person public killing that you did i
don't know what the numbers that they
had i think their number is some
ridiculous number that they have public
assassination that they had last year
the numbers like 50 people that they
killed don't forget the
the wrestler what iran did i think
china's the leader of 250 something but
don't forget what you rounded yeah
you do one of those you lose your money
if we get one time
hearing from the top politicians threat
to america that's recorded
you're losing your money if you don't
allow fox bbc cnn abc nbc's any of those
guys
in iran you're losing your money if you
do one more attack
on you're losing your money if i'm gonna
put if if you
in your textbook in school if we see in
your textbook in schools
you're talking about how shitty of a
country america is and how much we're
the enemy you're losing your money
the greatest say if you want to keep
doing that you're losing our money
that's how you give money you don't give
money and say please be nice to us
please let's make this work can i have
you ever been able to buy
say the girl you love the most have you
ever been able to buy love
no how much money has been able to buy
love nothing
even the guy who died couldn't buy anna
on nicole smith's uh love
he you know the billionaire that married
anna nicole smith so
you ain't buying no love she's just
buying the money is what you of course
you cannot buy love you cannot buy peace
well she also had an expiration date
apparently so she used too much drugs
she couldn't control her exactly
but she had lower back problems which
was attractive to him which was
attractive to him that's what he liked
you didn't see the scientific side of it
that's that's called that's called
failing in biology
but paying attention to the right areas
of life okay so you bring up another
point you say
you know you you take also look at north
korea right
do you think you know there's a variety
of positions
that are out there but the south koreans
have been
very frustrated by the entire rest and
the japanese by the entire rest of the
west
to not permanently de-arm
north korea and you have another lunatic
that gets paid off in foreign aid
but he doesn't stop making weapons and
every now and then he's on an
anniversary date
he launches another sub-ballistic
missile
into the into the ocean and everybody
looks at this
gosh he's crazy why isn't he stopped
well you've given a bunch of money and
he keeps doing research and he keeps
doing it and he promised he wouldn't do
it
next time yeah this is not going away
tom i mean people have to remember i'm
saying this is the method that
yeah there there is a method that
believes there is a political
position within the left that believes
that appeasement
through aid creates peace it doesn't
no zero no no no zero look
you know what you're talking about has
played out in north korea too
how many awards do we have the last four
years how many awards do we have the
last four years
buy a personality no words no no how
many new wars
caused by uh trump no wha what what
countries did he unite the last four
years
a lot of peace deals in the middle east
how how
how did a personality like his do to do
that
how many wars during obama how many how
many
how how how many wars did you see how
much how many how many times did you see
terrorist attacks how many times did you
see isis how many times in the news did
you hear about isis every day we walk up
isis
debate topics isis debate topics isis
what isis topic did you see in single
debate the last four years
what happened because the enemy needs to
at least
respect you and fear you what you're
capable of
see when i sat with sammy i talked to
sammy and i asked him a question sent me
to will gravano i said sammy
there are some people that say john
gotti never killed anybody he always
told people to go kill somebody
he says don't get it twisted john is
capable
he says that's all that matters in the
world i was a part of i said what do you
mean capable
he says he's capable of taking your life
so i wouldn't cross them
that's all you have to realize and
because of that they didn't
so the point with politics is they have
to know
if they push the envelope you're willing
to go to extreme measures
you don't buy peace and that's exactly
what they try to do